hi i'm alvin i'm a tasty producer and
these are some of my most viral recipes
i'll be showing you how to make my
barbecue rib sandwich to feed a crowd so
this recipe is pretty cool because it's
basically a giant version of that
favorite fast food rib sandwich that
pretty much everybody knows it requires
a entire slab of baby back ribs which is
kind of awesome because
i love ribs i love meat
so basically the concept is that you
cook barbecue ribs pretty normally and
you just add some seasoning some you
know your glaze your barbecue sauce to
make a nice rack of ribs
so the funny thing is the idea came to
me at a very weird time i was like in my
dorm like senior year of college and
like at like 1 30 a.m i was like
browsing the internet looking for
barbecue videos to fall asleep too i saw
this video where they had taken a giant
slab of barbecue ribs and
they were like oh my god like i think
they flipped it over and then he wanted
to show the camera how
how tender the meat was so he like took
one of the bones out and i was like oh
my god like you just straight up pull
the bone right out of the rib the person
did that to show how tender it was and i
was like whoa but wait
what happens if you take all of them out
so i had this brain blast at like 2 am
laying in bed on like a week night and i
was like i want to try this kind of
slowly pull the bone
right out of each sort of rib and the
key here is actually not to just tear it
out you want to keep as much of it as
intact as possible because you want it
to be a nice sandwich but the tricky
thing is you know
if it's super tender it's gonna fall out
that's totally fine um and i gotta say
when i was making this video i
definitely like the moment i first
pulled a bone out it was just so
satisfying in all the right in all the
wrong ways that i just like kept doing
it and i was like man i should probably
record this
i was like pulling out the bones from a
very close-up angle for a very long time
so kind of after that's done
you kind of cook it normally as you
would
[Music]
and the trickiest part is transferring
that slab of beautiful glazed meat onto
a nice bun and the key here is to
actually get a nice piece of toasted
bread that matches whatever the uh ribs
you're gonna make so as long as you get
some bread and you toast it and you
butter it and it fits with the rib
you know you can add whatever toppings
you want i like onions so i chose to add
onions and some parsley
[Music]
the coolest part is when you actually
serve it because when you slice it along
the edges of the sandwich you're
actually going to get one rib per person
and it's cause like that's like one
sandwich per person
so you just cut it up into what you
think where the ribs were everybody gets
a nice sandwich that they can
just chomp on and it's you know it's
like a boneless rib and what could be
better than that i was surprised it
actually turned out really well it's
kind of like your childhood uh you know
fast food rib sandwich reimagined with
actual ribs because who knows what's in
the original one and if you know you do
make it tag me send it over i think it's
awesome when you guys make our recipes
so i think that's a keeper for sure if
you want to entertain if you just want
some ribs or if you're just looking for
lunch like me on a weekly basis
[Music]
during my time at tasty i've gone
through a lot of phases there was you
know the giant food phase and at one
point the recurring phase was the layer
phase i
absolutely love layers i think they're
beautiful i think that can be really
cool very visual very stunning and can
incorporate a lot of flavor so i was
definitely in a phase of just making
foods that had beautiful layers to them
i love cheesecake a lot of people love
cheesecake i love cookies and cream a
lot of people love cookies and cream so
i had this idea of making a cookies and
cream cheesecake that was just purely
black and white but had the cleanest
layers possible
the thought process was that i would
take you know the base would be the
cookies the filling would be the
cheesecake that also uses the fillings
from the cookies and the top would be a
thin layer of like those like pulverized
like ground or fine powdered of the
cookies so you get like a black white
black look so pretty much is you start
with the base you make the filling and
then you do the top so the base is just
crushed pulverized cookies that you mix
with some butter
[Music]
you bake like a graham cracker crust
it's pretty simple you just put it in
and bake it you kind of really want to
press it flat so there's no huge lumps
so that goes in and after you separate
the filling from the cookies you want to
save the cookie filling to make sure
that you can use that for the cheesecake
filling mix out with some cream cheese
and it's a pretty standard piece of
batter recipe what makes this a no-bake
recipe is that it uses gelatin to help
set the mixture so gelatin mixture is
then whisked back in to the cheesecake
mixture so it creates this really smooth
really nice really velvety kind of
texture that also has the melted cookie
filling in it so you don't really waste
anything here it's kind of you know you
separate the cookie into the crust you
separate the filling into the cheesecake
and it's basically redefining the shape
of what the cookie looked like in the
first plate once that filling is set you
want to pour that into the
baked cheesecake mold and that kind of
sets in the fridge you want to make sure
that it's as smooth as possible no lumps
if you really need to and you see lumps
and flecks of stuff
you can sieve it you can patch it
through a mesh sieve to get rid of any
impurities if you really want to that
goes in the fridge for a very long time
if you actually want the cleanest layers
possible you can throw it in the freezer
it's not going to make a difference the
taste and the texture because by the
time you serve it it's going to be cold
anyways and the reason why i didn't bake
this one is because when you bake a
cheesecake
i'm maybe i'm not good at it but i found
it pretty difficult to get like this
perfect smooth like top layer with no
bumps no dips no crevices or anything so
i went for the no-bake route so this
recipe is pretty simple and the key i
think to really getting those clean
layers is after the whole thing is done
you do want to put it back into the
fridge or the freezer if you put it in
the freezer you will get the sharpest
cleanest layers possible this is one of
my personal secrets for cutting cakes
cutting cheesecakes cutting pies is
either freezing them or semi-freezing
them because the knife goes through it
goes straight down it doesn't bend it
doesn't really drag on anything it
really helps give you those nice clean
layers so it's a play on a cheesecake
that i think was very fun it satisfied
my layer cravings at the time although i
definitely made a lot more layered stuff
after that
it is a no-bake cheesecake so you don't
actually have to use your oven
but it is a fun recipe it doesn't
require too much cooking
if you do make it let me know i'll be
here
making my layered stuff so happy baking
or no baking in this case
[Music]
i'll be teaching you how to make my
prime rib with garlic butter
[Music]
so prime rib is commonly eaten around
the holidays and i love prime rib i love
steak steak is my number one favorite
thing to eat and to make in the entire
world if you don't know what prime rib
is it is essentially just a bunch of rib
eyes stacked together it is what rib
eyes would be if you did not cut steaks
from them and for the seasoning this is
just a very seasoned garlic butter with
a lot of spices it's just going to help
the primer get a lot of flavor and it's
going to taste really awesome garlic and
butter go really well with the steak so
why not just have it with prime rib and
this method you're kind of coating the
whole thing i know it's a lot of butter
but it's going to help flavor this huge
piece of meat it's going to melt off
we're going to use that later so don't
worry about it and it's the holidays
you're not trying to diet i hope not if
you are maybe don't watch the rest of
this video uh cause it's a lot of butter
this technique is actually very
interesting i was actually trying it for
the first time this is like the 500
degree technique where you put it in the
oven super super hot 500 degrees for
around 30 minutes depending on the
weight and size of your roast and then
you do this technique where you just you
turn the oven off but you leave the door
closed and you do not open it because
the residual heat is supposed to
continue to cook the prime rib all the
way through it's gonna smell great it's
gonna look great you cannot open the
door if you open the oven door the
heat's just gonna come out you're just
gonna have a raw prime rib and that's no
good if your oven has a fan that helps
take away that heat this method will not
work it's just going to end up raw so
double check that your fan doesn't try
to carry away that extra heat or else
you need to look up some other cooking
methods for the prime rib i cook it to
medium rare you can cook it however you
like just anything besides medium rare
probably can't be my friend
you take it out after that two hours or
two and a half hours you let it rest and
while that kind of you know happens on
the side we want to make a gravy because
prime rib is essentially cooked as a
whole roast it's actually not going to
get super seasoned all the way through
so when you slice it you actually need
to make sure that you have some sort of
seasoning or sauce in this case we're
going to make a gravy what you can do is
you can use the drippings from the pan
that you made the prime ribbon which was
the beef fat all that butter all those
flavors all those juices that garlic
it's still in there don't waste it so
you're going to want to strain out take
out any of the super burnt bits leave
behind the fat and the juices combine
that you know with some flour with some
beef stock and some other things and
kind of cook it over heat until it gets
nice and thick into a sauce so that's
gonna be the gravy for the prime rib um
it's pretty awesome and you can season
as you go when i was making this video
actually it was pretty late i think it
was like even a weekend where it was
just the super expensive huge chunk of
rib eye and i really did not want to
mess it up and i was very scared i was
gonna you know make it you know mess it
up and have to spend more money to get
it right and it is an expensive cut so
make sure that you do treat it well if
you have a meat thermometer that'll save
you a lot of headache into knowing if
it's cooked or not you want to aim for
around 130 to 135 if you're going for
medium rare anything higher than that is
just more well done and my favorite part
is just really just it's that reveal
it's when you first get that nice thick
slice out of there and the whole thing
just comes out it's juicy it's pink it's
perfectly cooked you plate it with some
nice mashed potatoes you plate it with
some nice vegetables you support some
gravy you kind of drench it in gravy for
me and that's pretty much it you kind of
go ham you go in and you try not to get
a second slice but knowing me i'm gonna
get like three slices so yeah if you do
make it let me know send over pictures
ask me questions it's you know one of my
favorite recipes of all time we've ever
made on tasty one of the proudest i've
ever been happy to help you guys out and
i just want you guys to enjoy your steak
as much as i do
making these recipes is is honestly it's
not just fun but i think allows me to do
a lot of things that i do currently in
life and have done before it is
something that i enjoy it when i'm able
to make other people happy by giving
them food because that makes me happy
and making tasty videos is essentially
being able to make hundreds and
thousands and if not millions of people
happy in a certain way and i think
that's just pretty awesome so if you do
make it let me know i really love seeing
when people make and i think it's just
pretty awesome
[Music]
[Music]
you